un film qui réunit un générique tout à
fait prestigieux le réalisateur tout
d'abord guisspé tanatoré prix spécial du
jury en 90 pour Cinéma Paradiso
l'écrivain Pascal Quignard pour les
dialogues et Eno moriconet pour la
musique reportage Nicole cornul
glloire depuis 20 ans c'est l'escalade
de pardieu vers la gloire et l'émeutes
de film en film il ne manque aucun
rendez-vous avec la Croisette et chacun
de ces passages lui ressemble énorme et
Tony Truant enin
il a monté les marches des deux palais
l'ancien et le nouveau avec des stars ou
avec des copains il a reçu des
récompenses on a remis en tant que
président du jury et si aujourd'hui il
protège son copain polansski c'est parce
qu'ils sont les protagonistes d'un
fantastique
interrogatoire
écoutez